one of the things that i love about
working for amazon as a data scientist
i get time to research ideas come up
with proposals
develop solutions and really innovate in
my role
hi there my name is caleb lee i am a
data science manager in amazon i lead a
team of business intelligence engineers
data engineers and data scientists and
we provide
scientific and analytical solutions to
serve alexa music initiatives
everyone my name is constantinos
papianes i'm an applied scientist and
i've worked in the alexa hml team for
almost two years now
my name is jinding i'm a proud scientist
in amazon now i'm in prime media finance
team my name is patrick
i'm a data scientist in amazon's
networking team based here in sydney
my name is julian pachon and i am the
director and chief scientist for amazon
last month scientists and amazon
owners the fun part of my job is to turn
data driven evidence into business
decision making
we love trying out new ideas for example
this could be a new way of slicing the
data it could be a new tool to process
the data
it could be another methodology for
comparison purposes
or just a whole new business problems to
solve customer obsession
help us make sure we're focusing on
actual customer needs
things that customers would use in their
day-to-day lives and that would
make their lives better we're not
limited to the problem we want the
project to solve
we also think about how these projects
can benefit
other amazon team or the open source
community
as a science team the principle that i
value the most
is invent and simplify you know our job
is to innovate we need to constantly
look for new ways of how to do things
and so we experiment a lot in the
experimentation we also
fail a lot and but we aim to fail fast
and when we do that
then we drive innovation
you